The Damped Vibrations
applet illustrates
several different
concepts related
to differential equations.
Initial conditions for
second-order equations,
the phase plane for
autonomous equations,
and damping conditions
for second-order
homogeneous linear equations.
The differential we're studying
appears at upper right.
And the parameter
names reflect the fact
that this equation describes
a mass-spring-dashpot system,
with mass m, dashpot constant
b, and spring constant k.
The right-hand side of
the equation is zero.
There's no forcing term.
The equation is homogeneous.
The sliders at bottom
control the values
of the system parameters.
With the selected
values for m, b, and k,
the solutions are
damped vibrations.
I can let the solution evolve
by grabbing the time slider
or by using the
animation key, which also
serves to stop the animation.
If the value of the
solution gets too small,
I can blow the picture
up using the zoom slider
at the upper left.
Moving it to the right
squeezes the solutions.
Moving it to the left
makes them larger.
The window on the left lets
you set the initial condition
of the system.
There are two components
to the initial condition
of a second-order equation.
Position and velocity,
that is x and x dot.
Together they form
the coordinates
of a point on this plane.
I can grab the point
and change both x and x
prime simultaneously.
The x-coordinate is
written vertically,
because that's how it's written
on the right-hand graphing
window.
And you can see that they
keep pace with each other.
The horizontal component is
x dot, the initial velocity.
That's positive when
we're to the right,
and becomes negative
when we're to the left.
The left window
represents phase space.
For any time t, the
values of x and x dot
are the coordinates of
a point in phase space.
And as the solution
evolves through time,
that point follows
a path, sweeps out
a path in phase space.
And with these selected
choices of m, b, and k,
the path is a spiral.
This reflects the
fact that both x and x
dot undergo a damped vibration.
The system parameters can
be set using these sliders
at lower left.
Let's suggest the mass to be
1/2 and leave k to be one,
and watch what happens
to the solutions
as we vary the
damping constant b.
When b is small, the solution
doesn't damp out as quickly,
and when b is large, it
damps out more quickly.
These things become much clearer
when you think about them
in terms of the roots of the
characteristic polynomial
of this equation.
And we can display those roots
by clicking the roots button
here.
What's shown here
is the complex plane
with the roots of the
characteristic polynomial drawn
on it.
Also we have a readout of the
two roots in green over here.
So let's watch what
happens when we adjust b.
I'm going to start
with b equal to zero.
In this case,
there's no damping.
The solutions are
sinusoidal, the roots
of the characteristic
polynomial are purely imaginary,
and the trajectory in
phase space is an ellipse.
Both the solution and its
derivative vary sinusoidally.
As I increase b away
from zero, I get spirals.
And at the same time, the roots
move off the imaginary axis.
They acquire a negative real
part, which is minus b over 2m,
incidentally.
And as I increase b further,
the spiral opens up,
the damping occurs
more quickly, the roots
move away from the
imaginary axis.
They increase the size
of their real part.
The damping occurs more quickly.
And you'll notice that
they get closer and closer
to the real axis as well.
Their imaginary
part is decreasing.
That means that the circular
frequency, the angular
frequency of the
solution, is decreasing.
The period, or pseudo-period
of the solution is decreasing.
You can see that in the
graph, but it's much clearer
to see what's happening
to these roots
of the characteristic
polynomial.
There are converging
on the real axis,
and eventually they merge into
a double root on the real axis.
This is critical damping.
From the readout, we
see that the value of b
seems to be about 1.41.
Why don't you take a
moment and calculate
what b is for these
values of m and k
when critical damping occurs?
If we continue to increase
b beyond critical damping,
now the roots move
out on the real axis.
There are two
exponential solutions,
and the general solution is
a linear combination of them.
And there's no oscillation
in any solution.